any of this hit maneuver stuff in
j-turns and high-speed backing if you're
using any of those skills you've done
something probably really silly or just
gotten into it all hornet's nest at
trouble all of a sudden
[Music]
my name is Wyatt Knox and I'm the
special projects director here at the
team O'Neil Riley school I've been
instructing professionally high speed
driving high risk driving for over a
decade now so I started rallying when I
was 18 or 19 years old and I do a few a
year 2012 I did the entire national US
Championship but I won two-wheel drive
the definition of rally racing getting
from point A to point B quickly with the
vehicle still running underneath you is
basically the definition of tactical
driving tactical mobility in a nutshell
is basically having excellent car
control so that if something happens you
know you're capable of handling your
vehicle and its occupant safely and also
being able to respond to other potential
happenings depending on what sort of a
mission you might be involved in for the
most parts of the folks that we put
through these types of courses here at
the rally school are with the United
States and friendly governments
venturing into special operations folks
we spend a lot of time in some pretty
rough places around the world
disclaimer a lot of the stuff that we're
doing here on our private 600 acre
facility hidden away in the mountains of
New Hampshire is training folks for high
risk environments overseas it's
definitely not for the roads of America
and that sort of thing tactical mobility
the way that we train it here getting
really really good car control in all
different kinds of vehicles and then
introducing some of the offensive and
defensive skills that you might need so
this car is a Ford Crown Victoria it
makes a really excellent training
platform for us because it's
representative of so many heavy American
rear-wheel drive automatic vehicles that
are commonly used by you know security
professionals a rear-wheel drive car
like this when you accelerate the rear
tire spin and the back end of the car
swings all over the place so it's really
good for training and getting into a
bunch of skids and sliding around and
learning how to handle that we do weld
on these big heavy duty steel bumpers so
that we can run into each other without
doing so much damage but they've got
good suspension and really thick wheels
and tires and stuff from the factory we
have snow tires on this one you can see
it's met some
the other cars and then we just do the
the big steel bumpers in the back
alright so we're gonna set up a course
out here take this car out and run
through some representative scenarios
that you might find out in the real
world alright so a j-turn is essentially
just a reverse 180 you're gonna use a
j-turn if you're driving along down the
road and up ahead for whatever reason
you see something you don't like you'd
much rather be going the other direction
quickly j-turns it's kind of a Hollywood
movie you see it a ton in the action
movies and TV shows and that kind of
thing
it's not something that you know a lot
of people are really gonna use
operationally overseas especially if
you're in you know an armored SUV are
you gonna do a j-turn no it's gonna flip
over if you're in a congested urban area
are you gonna do a j-turn no you're
gonna run into something but if you've
got enough area and you've deemed hey we
need to be going backwards at high speed
right now the more tools you have in the
toolbox that better off you're gonna be
come to a full and complete stop get it
into reverse back up we usually give it
the count of three so one two three let
off the throttle and turn add a little
bit of brake and you can get the car to
snap around nice and quick while it's
rotating engaged drive straighten the
wheel and get out of there the pit
maneuver is basically a pursuit
technique when you need the vehicle that
is in front of you to either get out of
your way or come to a stop it's
necessary to do that by doing as little
harm to your own vehicle as possible
here comes looks like in order for the
police to use it it's considered use of
deadly force here in America so unless
whatever that person has done warrants
that you're not gonna see that but you
will see it you know very commonly
overseas you can do a pit maneuver on
either side of the vehicle the reason
that most folks in the United States you
know the police departments used to
train match your left front to their
right rear because it's easier for the
driver and you're spinning them away
from oncoming traffic for police
Department use say this is your target
vehicle for a PIT maneuver kind of this
sweet spot that you're going for is
right in this area right here if you're
too far to the back chances are you'll
just damage the car without actually
spinning it out enough and if you get up
into the wheel and that sort of thing
you're gonna do a lot of damage to your
own vehicle and it might not work out so
well you're following a vehicle lagging
behind when you decide it's time drive
up quickly match your left front with
their right rear make contact turn in
and accelerate and if you do it just
right and drive through them that cars
gonna spin out and even for an expert
it's not going to be recoverable and
they'll be spun around and stopped a
much more useful skill and than being
super good at j-turns is actually just
being able to backup at high speed if
you're an urban environment you need to
back around you know back through
traffic and park vehicles you're not
gonna be doing j-turns
when you're backing up a lot of the
engineering that's gone into making your
car perform the way that it does is
working against you whenever you're in
Reverse your car's rear steer if your
cars rear-wheel drive and now it's
front-wheel drive even the way that the
brakes work and everything else cars are
not designed to drive quickly backwards
and most drivers are just not great at
it
the easiest sneaky trick is to get your
left arm over the seatbelt brace your
left foot kind of over where the dead
pedal might be and turn yourself around
in the seat you know as much as possible
and my hand is at what would be 12
o'clock if the wheel were straight
I'm not very good at high-speed backing
I will need one more time good you've
got to be good with your mirrors and so
hopefully you've got them adjusted and
you've got a little bit of wherewithal
and it's not that tricky it's nice you
got both hands on the wheel washing your
left side and your right side and
backing through you know traffic or
around some obstacles and the best thing
you can do is get backed into a side
street or an alleyway or something like
that get it into drive so you can really
get some speed up and get out of there
if you're ever the passenger in a
vehicle and for whatever reason the
driver becomes incapacitated to the
pourer they're no longer able to operate
that vehicle anymore somebody's diabetic
or if they're prone to seizures or
anything like that
that's where hopefully you've practiced
the driver down drill you're in the
passenger seat something happens and you
realize that the driver is no longer
able to operate the vehicle
appropriately first step is get your
belt off and reach across to grab the
handle on the door not the handle it
opens it but like the safety handle and
that'll just help kind of hold them in
position while you scoot over
basically sweep their legs out of the
way and you're going to be operating the
pedals with your left foot only and the
steering wheel with your right hand on
the way that we train it is
yeah you've actually got to get through
some exercises like that so that you're
pretty capable and you can make it
around a few turns and then get the
vehicle to a stop some of the folks that
are headed overseas to pretty hostile
environments will train the same drill
but with you know three men in the car
four men in the car the driver down
drill at that point turns into passenger
takes control rear seat gets the driver
out do what you can for them
passenger moves completely into the
driver's seat car continues driving
most drivers out there on the street are
probably just okay driving around with
perfectly normal kind of unaltered
vehicles but it's good to be able to do
some of these things and to go through
this training and have those skills and
know how to prepare vehicles so that if
for some reason you do need to just
drive at the limit or get through some
different situations you've got those
skills personally when I'm looking for a
vehicle I either select an older vehicle
that doesn't have ABS in traction
control and that sort of thing or at
least an older vehicle it's usually easy
to disable you know in this two thousand
two or three Subaru I can pull a fuse or
two and in about thirty seconds we're
analog no electronics ready to go have a
good time slide around corners basically
driving with ABS and traction control is
like swimming with a life jacket on you
know it's really easy to swim and you
can swim around just fine but abs and
traction control limit your car's
performance a dramatic amount on a
slippery road you can't really stop that
well you can't get uphill sometimes it
can be frustrating but abs and traction
control and also stability control
they're all wonderful systems and
they've definitely saved lives so the
first time you approach an unfamiliar
vehicle there's kind of a little
checklist that you can do even if you
just have a second look at one side or
do a quick walk around number ones
always going to be tires what kind of
condition are they in do they have air
in them or do they have tread so a
winter tires much softer rubber like a
pencil eraser almost you can hit it with
your thumb and kind of squish it around
and that's what you're looking for in
very cold temperatures to stay stuck to
the road just gauging the tire pressure
usually you can give it just the thumb
test is just pushing in on the middle of
the sidewall and you should get you know
a quarter inch of deflection or so too
hard is not really a problem if it's too
soft it'll overheat and you'll have a
blowout if a car like this might be
strange to you get yourself in get your
seat in your steering wheel properly
adjust it and adjust your mirrors it's
really this silly stuff that ends up
biting people the mirrors haven't been
adjusted or you don't know where the
wipers are and you hit a big mud puddle
and then you're turning the headlights
on and whacking the stereo and trying to
figure it all out and it really only
takes 30 seconds to a minute of sitting
in a car
make yourself kind of happy with it and
you're good to go so we've got here is a
Subaru WRX it's an all-wheel-drive
turbocharged car we don't have any ABS
or traction control active on this it's
fully analog we're gonna take this car
put it through its paces and a few
exercises out here at the rallies cool
most of the skills that we're teaching
here at the rally school are rally based
skills the Scandinavians came up with
left foot breaking for the most part
using left foot braking in front-wheel
drive cars to get around corners faster
doing the pendulum turns you know it's
called the Scandinavian flick by most
people's intentionally chucking the car
sideways to get around corners they were
really the early masters of this kind of
car control and it's developed since
then as cars have gotten a little better
and tires and suspensions have gotten a
little better there's more kinds of
racing that have used left foot braking
now basically everybody's doing you know
there's a lot of different reasons for
left foot braking the first one is
always just gonna be reaction time being
able to get to the brake very quickly
lets you drive a lot faster a lot more
safely one of the other main reasons for
left foot braking is to be able to
control the weight of the car part of
what you're doing is putting weight on
the front to help the car turn and if
the backend slides around because of
that you need to put weight on the back
for stability and that's what you're
doing with your right foot on the
throttle and your left foot on the brake
is just transferring weight smoothly to
the front and smoothly to the rear
there's a common misconception in the
world right now that a skidding car is
out of control because if you schedule
crash and the truth is there's a huge
amount of gray area in there
where you're skidding around and you're
sliding a car but you're well under
control and that's really where you're
getting the most performance out of you
know any vehicle you watch a dirt bike
they're always spinning tires and
locking tires up and sliding around
corners it's the same with cars it's
just people have forgotten how to do it
and most people were never taught how to
do it and now most cars come with
systems that don't even allow you to do
it one really important skill to have if
you're traveling to these high risk
environments is to be able to move other
objects and/or vehicles out of your way
as necessary
if you need to breach a barricade with a
vehicle or get through some kind of
roadblock the most important thing is
knowing where the strong points on your
car and those are gonna be your two
frame rails in the front sometimes
they're closer together or further apart
or higher up or lower down and you're
gonna want to line those up directly
with whatever it is you're trying to
move out of the way with a vehicle
blocking the road you're gonna line up
one of your frame rails with the rear
wheel of the vehicle that you're trying
to move if you happen to see that it's a
pickup truck that's fraida down in the
back sure go for the front whichever end
looks lighter usually it's the back of
that's where you're gonna want to square
up with and push out of the way and if
you can manage to hit that rear wheel
with your frame rail you're just gonna
break that contact patch with the ground
of those rear wheels and push that car
out of your way very easily without
doing really any damage to your own car
be aware in a normal car your airbags
are gonna go off the fuel pump might
shut off and you're now gonna be
stranded right in the worst possible
situation just having done something
really stupid most vehicles that are
kind of fleet supplied to the folks that
we work with that are going overseas
that stuff's all deactivated really the
baseline of all of the training that we
do here is car control and that comes
from just spending hours sliding cars
around and learning where the roads
limits and your own limits and different
vehicles limits all exist and it just
gives you a tremendous amount of
capabilities to get in and out perform
90 something percent of normal drivers
that might be out there on the road
[Music]
making decisions based on what you're
presented with is one way to exercise
your mind and learn how to pay attention
to the small things that was a special
agent with the FBI my job was to catch
spies retired Navy SEAL 21-years combat
experience and now at crisis management
professional I've been instructing
professionally high-speed driving with
the United States and from the
government if you take the time to
evaluate walking or driving that same
route every day you just reduced the
number of things you have to pay
attention to when something bad occurs